14 січня Росія вкотре завдала масованого
ракетного удару по критичній та цивільні
інфраструктурі України різних типами
крилатих та авіаційних ракет 25 із 38
знищила українська ППО серед тих які не
вдалося перехопити крилаті ракети х22
одна з них влучила у житловий будинок у
Дніпрі з великою кількістю жертв серед
мирних мешканців за словами командування
повітряних сил ЗСУ українська ППО не
здатна збивати такий тип ракет для цього
потрібні сучасні зенітні ракетні
комплекси на кшталт-петріут чи сампті
також Київщину рефатакувала новими
ракетами із зрк с-400 для виявлення
перехоплення яких ЗСУ поки теж не мають
ефективних засобів оглядачі не
виключають що Росія вдалася до такої
тактики Бо Україна навчилася ефективно
збивати інші типи ворожих ракет та
успішно відбивати атаки Дронів Камікадзе
зокрема у Новорічну ніч Українські сили
ППО збили 100 випущених Росією
безпілотників 45 із 45 та 39 у ніч із
першого на 2 січня загалом же з вересня
від початку застосування іранських
шухедів українська ППО знищила понад 540
ворожих Дронів щоправда для цього
Україна докладає багато зусиль і
витрачає чимало коштів бережучий
136 скажімо якщо берем його ну це
небезпечна зброя це високоточна зброя це
далекобійна зброя яка летить на великі
дистанції яка вражає цим точно яка має
яка летить по прокладеному маршруту який
який прокладають з метою подолати нашу
систему протиповітряної оборони власне
летить вона точно ціль як знаєте її
застосовують групами що ускладнює роботу
наших засобів наприклад оборони про них
Росія використовує дрони Камікадзе щоб
бити по мирних містах і руйнувати
критичну цивільну інфраструктуру України
проти них постійно змінює тактику
запускає безпілотники вночі пускає її
групами за різними маршрутами чи вздовж
течії Дніпра тому щоб збити ворожі цілі
Україна використовує цілий комплекс
засобів протиповітряної оборони розповів
дверечник командування повітряних сил
ЗСУ то Чим же Україна збиває іранський
дрони камікадзе
зенітно ракетні комплекси
найчастіше і найефективніший дрони
Камікадзе збивають зенітно-ракетними
комплексами вони здатні виявити і
знищити цілі яка летить уночі хоча
раніше вдень проти цих безпілотників
застосовували і зенітні гармати та
крупнокаліберну стрілецьку зброю
наприклад крупнокаліберні кулемети
ракетні комплекси які у нас є на
озброєнні основа нашого зрвця Буки М1
S300 ними ефективно знищуються
найефективніше збиває зрозуміло їх
засоби які мають радіолокаційні системи
так які мають розбілокаційні засоби
мається на увазі які захоплюють ціль і
знищують їх в цьому режимі
при цьому те що застарілі радянські
системи такі як Буки М1 S300 та с-125
поступово доповнюють західними набагато
ефективнішими комплексами німецькими
айрісті Та норвезькими насамбс вони за
словами Юрія ігната посилюють українську
оборону і дають кращий результат у
збитті повітряних цілей
поки що лише одна установка у складі
однієї батареї в найближчим часом вже є
Олаф шольц обіцяв уже
решта установок доправити Україну і щоб
допоможе наростити спроможності цієї
батареї яка буде охоплювати значно
більший повітряний простір захищати
нашої держави наші що критичної
інфраструктуру та інші об'єкти насамств
- це норвезький комплекс якого на
озброєння американські ракети а їм 120
амром Саме ці комплекси надані
сполученими штатами Америки в Україні
Саме ці комплекси де різних захищають
небо столиці була успішна робота зокрема
і новорічну ніч на самців це дві батареї
Вони теж не в повному складі хотілося б
щоб кава потреба була доповнена кожного
з них і більшою кількістю саме пускових
установок ті всі комплекси які ми маємо
сьогодні на озброєнні айріс на самс Та
не будемо мати патріот це найкраще що я
сьогодні так у світі хотілося б ще і сам
в ті французько-італійський комплекс
який міг би теж доповнити і я теж як і
петріот може збивати і балістичні цілі
при цьому важливо ще й постійно
поповнювати боєприпаси то вже
доставлених сучасних систем
протиповітряної оборони
винищувальна авіація у тих зонах які не
перекриті засобами протиповітряної
оборони піднімають винищувальну авіацію
військові льотчики неодноразово
ефективно протистояли одразу кільком
шахедам наприклад Пілот з позивним карая
збив 5 ворожих Дронів Камікадзе над
Вінницею
мобільні вогневі групи із ПЗРК останнім
часом ефективність довели мобільні
вогневі групи які мають на озброєнній і
зенітні гармати і ПЗРК тобто переносні
зенітно-ракетні комплекси Stinger і два
та інші у них є великий досвід і ціла
команда яка працює над тим щоб виявити
захопити і знищити ціль мені треба
виявити по-перше є система зв'язку
оповіщення є візуальні пости
спостереження які дозволяють дуже швидко
визначати координувати дії І передавати
цю інформацію безпосередньо оператору
ПЗРК який може здійснювати уже стрільбу
більш ефективно треба розуміти що
прожектором треба його спіймати по-перше
шахе от Скажімо так по-друге ввести його
так супроводжувати щоб був він в тій
стороні світла і знову ж таки інша
людина яка сидить за крупнокаліберним
кулеметом чи за сприймає теж вправно
стріляти на випередження по корпусу
треба щоб ми його бити коректування
балістичне тому не все так просто але
наші хлопці справляються
самохідні Зенітні установки також
застосовується Я вже назвав самохідні
установки гепард ну працює зрозуміло ще
ППО сухопутних військ такі комплекси як
оса це зенітна ракетний комплекс Ну він
малого радіусу дій поряд з ним уже
працює французький крутай який є теж
надзвичайно ефективним у збитті цих
повітряних цілей наші теж такі як шилка
Тунгуска є
зрозуміло що західні зразки набагато
ефективніші у виявлені та знищені
станції реб
на певних ділянках фронту застосовують
засоби радіоелектронної боротьби які
можуть знешкоджувати ворожі дрони Утім
покритий заглушити повністю настільки
велику за протяжністю лінію фронту як в
Україні неможливо крім того шахеди
використовують кілька систем GPS
навігації тому не завжди вдається обійти
усі одразу тоді дрони врешті-решт
потрібно збивати наразі на боротьбу з
іранськими дронами Україна витрачає в
рази більше грошей ніж коштують самі
ворожі БПЛА це визначили аналітики
спільноти Мольфар які провели
дослідження на основі відкритих джерел і
з'ясували скільки Дронів Камікадзе збили
українські військові Яким видом зброї і
скільки це коштувало Україні
145 тисяч доларів є ручний
там один постріл коштує 60-80 тисяч
доларів тому що він по суті одноразовий
і за рахунок цього така ціна
Зараз ми перейдемо такого напевно до
найбільш коштовного пострілу це
батарея по насамбс там один постріл може
коштувати відкрити 100 тисяч до 3 млн
Незалежності від того скільки
опускається але з того що я бачу
використовують коли об'єкт вже підлітає
на досить дуже близько до міста мого чи
до якоїсь критичної інфраструктури Я
також
такого які придбала Німеччина і різці
там в принципі ціна схожа на Санс
близько 400 тисяч доларів один постріл з
американського стінгаря коштує 40 тисяч
доларів аби літ винищувача міг-29 може
коштувати до 700 тисяч доларів за даними
аналітиків лише у жовтні Україна збила
161 шакет вартістю приблизно
3,22 млн доларів А витратила на це від
12 до 18 мільйонів доларів якщо ми
дивимось на жов То тоді в деяких
випадках там умовно ми витрачали в 100
разів більше ніж коштує іранський Дрон
тому що він там умовно коштує там 23-40
тис доларів а один вистрілив з ППО в
залежності від типу може коштувати пі-
півмільйона доларів чи 300 000 далі Коли
ми зробили десь через місяць у листопаді
там Ми вийшли вже на оцінку ефективності
в 6-7 разів по ціні тобто умовно за
місяць Україну дуже сильно прогресує і
Якщо раніше ми змивали чисто через
погоду тоді з'явилися мобільні групи з
автоматами і ручними гранатометами
почали використовувати літаки які
злітались бували одразу декілька Дронів
у командування повітряних сил кажуть що
недоцільно порівнювати витрати на збиття
Дронів Камікадзе дорогими ракетами бо
потенційні збитки завдані ними
інфраструктурі значно вищі а життя людей
взагалі не можна виміряти грошима щоб
захистити населення та інфраструктуру
ЗСУ готові використовувати роботи усі
можливі засоби у нас було достатньо
більш дешевих засобів більше раціонально
використовувати нашу систему безумовно
ми б це робили але на даний час виходимо
з того що ми маємо очікуємо від наших
партнерів інших систем зокрема ППО
сухопутних військ і сумі гепарда якби
були великі кількості щоб їх можна було
розставити і захистити кожен наш об'єкт
критичної інфраструктури чи напрямки
відповідні тоді буде більше ефективно
Скільки вам витрачаємо на це збиття це
не так важливо тому що ми по факту
збиваємо і захищаємо життя людей і це
найважливіше другий основний план що
ефективність росте з кожним місяцем
наприклад от одна електростанція коштує
близько 30 мільйонів і якщо ми дивимось
ціну збиття одного дрона там навіть
200-300 тисяч доларів то це дуже
ефективно тому я вважаю що в цілому
Україна досить ефективно бореться з
дронами І взагалі не знаю гарних
показник цьому році 50% збиття в цьому
випадку ми збиваємо майже 90% за
останніми даними і цей показник ще
дедалі прогресує західні військові
експерти також вражені тим як Україна
навчилася ефективно збивати ворожій
безпілотники
враження що українська протиповітряна
оборона стає дедалі кращою і ми також
побачили що Україна змогла збити майже
100% безпілотників які летіли тож я
думаю що є ознаки дуже значного
покращення ми загалом дуже вражені
українським опором і українською
обороною проти усіх видів загроз
А коли йдеться про ракети та
безпілотники які хвилями направляють на
українські міста Ми багато чого вчимося
з того як українці захищають свої міста
та своїх людей
та щоб ефективність цієї боротьби
ставала вищою Україні потрібно постачати
більше дешевших систем протиповітряної
оборони вказує військовий експерт
Ми бачили як українські бійці збивали
безпілотники з кулеметів Ми бачили як
використовується авіаційні ракети Тому
все що є потрібно використовувати проти
цих безпілотників але в довгостроковій
перспективі якщо Росія надсилає сотні
тисячі цих безпілотників використання
дуже дорогих зенітних ракет не буде
ефективним тому для боротьби з цими
безпілотниками слід використовувати
електронні перешкоди глушилки та інші
більш дешеві інструменти
ракетний тероризм Росії триває Україна
готується до чергових ударів небезпеку
усвідомлюють і на заході зокрема США
нещодавно заявили що закуплять для
України 14 антидронових систем в імпає
ці установки допоможуть відстежувати і
збивати ворожі безпілотники та
захищатися від наземних загроз
противника ав встановити їх можна на
звичайній цивільній пікапи